here's something I want to ask you
should I interview more right-wingers
and when I say right-wingers it could be
Republican candidates or elected
officials
it could be conservative think-tank
people it could be the right-wing
extremists that I used to do much more
frequently like the Westboro Baptist
Church types or neo-nazis or whoever
else and the reason that this has come
up is that in the wake of my discussion
last week about attending politican this
political convention where political
conference where they have debates and
panels that might on some level be
interesting they might make for good
television but no real political issues
are going to be resolved the dialogue is
not going to be advanced by the types of
debates that by and large are happening
at politican so I went to the audience
and said what do you think is this
something that I should participate in
and in the wake of that a lot of people
emailed and they said you know I'm less
interested in political David but what I
would be interested in is you doing more
debates interviews debate style
interviews with people that are on the
right could be the far right could be
the less far right and I want to ask you
what you think about that because on the
one hand I don't subscribe to this idea
that dialogue merely for the sake of
dialogue is worth much if the dialogue
is happening in bad faith if the
dialogue is to people talking over each
other at the same time trying to score
political points without actually
discussing important issues so I don't
know we kind of go through phases where
we'll do more adversarial interviews and
then we'll kind of step back a little
bit from that they tend to do pretty
well in terms of audience interest and
audience size and feedback some people
like them more than others and I want to
sort of split the question up into two
one is are you interested in more
debates around policy with right-wingers
a libertarian about libertarian ideas or
someone who believes that low taxes on
the rich are good for the
sort of there's that and then the
question there is is it the same old
talking points all the time is there
anything new to learn or or achieve from
that that would be question one question
two is the other side of it which is
what about the more colorful extremists
do we want do you want me doing more
interviews with the homophobes the white
nationalists the religious ideologues
those types and does do we learn
anything from them it's fun to do it
it's fun to prepare for it they tend to
do well there's sort of like a shock
value but a lot of it devolves into
nonsense they very often won't answer
direct questions and and actually even
the right-wingers that I do sometimes
will debate on policy will use the
standard distraction tactics where I try
to really drill down on issues they
respond with non answers and
distractions like we all know the
techniques so is there something to be
gained what are the adversarial type
interviews that you want me to do what
are the ones that are maybe less
interesting to you and there's two views
on this often one is yes it's worth
getting people on and challenging their
ideas not necessarily because you're
going to change their mind but because
people will see it and it's the audience
whose mind may be changed it doesn't
really matter if you change one
libertarian economist mind but if
several thousand or tens of thousands of
people see that particular clip that's
where you might change the minds of a
hundred people or of a thousand people
or five hundred or who knows what the
number is the other side would be it's
just not worth a day but bring on people
who are coming up with innovative ideas
that we can get behind people on the
Left progressives and Social Democrats
and others let's talk to them and just
put good ideas out there I want to hear
from you you can let me know by using
the contact form at david pakman.com you
can tweet me at Deep hackman or tweet
the show at David Pakman show you can go
on our Facebook page facebook.com slash
David Pakman show you can even let me
know on Instagram if you
David Pakman on Instagram or at david
pakman show on instagram and by the way
if you're not following at david pakman
show on instagram please do lots of
interesting behind-the-scenes pictures
memes you can either even see what my
sort of temporary studio here in paris
france has looked like we've got a great
behind-the-scenes picture of the studio
up on the show instagram account at
david pakman show
so we'll take a quick break next we will
deal with the pseudoscience of detoxes
and cleanses in today's pseudo science
mini-series episode and then much much
more coming up including your voicemail
more news and eventually the bonus show